We have a lot to learn from science and
from medicine.
Yet sometimes it can be difficult to
understand exactly what we know and
what we need to know.
I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast Talk Smart,
The Podcast.
Today I am super excited to
chat with Dr Lloyd Minor,
Dean of the Stanford School of Medicine.
Lloyd is a scientist,
surgeon, and academic leader.
He is the Carl and
Elizabeth Naumann Dean of the Stanford
University School of Medicine.
He is also a Professor of Head and
Neck Surgery, and
a Professor of Bioengineering and
Neurobiology.
In 2020, he wrote the book
Discovering Precision Health,
and he is also the host of
the Minor Consult podcast.
Well, hi, Lloyd, I'm really excited
to have you on the podcast and
look forward to our conversation.
>> Thank you, Matt,
I'm delighted to be here and
I too look forward to our conversation.
>> Great, let's go ahead and get started.
First, to begin, congratulations on
your podcast, The Minor Consult.
I've listened in, and
I enjoy it very much.
I'm curious,
what led you to host a podcast and
what are you hoping to accomplish with it?
>> In the early days of COVID-19 when
there was a lot of information coming out,
a lot of science being done,
a lot that we didn't know.
I started doing some media appearances
really to try to explain what we do know
and what we don't know, to serve,
I hope, as a trusted information source.
And I enjoyed doing that and got good
feedback on it and really continued to do
that throughout the pandemic,
not that we're out of the pandemic yet.
But throughout the, shall we say,
the pre-vaccination stage and
vaccine rollout stage of the pandemic.
And so I was looking for a way to
continue that process of communicating
with a large group of people,
anyone who wants to listen, and
hopefully through the podcast,
also learn from the guests.
The podcast is about leadership.
It's about leadership in a crisis.
And I've had the privilege of interviewing
guests from different professions and
interests.
And I've learned a lot from it.
Hopefully the listeners have as well.
I think one of the central
messages of the pandemic to me and
I'll be processing these past two plus
years for the next how many, every year?
>> I think we all will, yeah.
Yeah, but one of the central messages is,
we need to be more thoughtful about,
more engaged with the way we communicate.
I think that's particularly
true in the science and
medical communities,
where I don't think our communication has
always served the public well or
the scientific interests well.
>> I hope we can start
that conversation today,
given that we focus
a lot on communication.
And I just want to give you
a personal nod and thank you.
During the pandemic,
you certainly provided a steady hand and
some good clear advice during times
of confusion, both for me personally,
I know for my colleagues and on the
campus, and actually in our general area.
So thank you for
that, and I'll just echo hosting
a podcast is a fantastic way to learn.
I have learned so much and I am sure
I will learn a ton from you as well.
Speaking of learning, I recently learned
that you consider yourself an introvert.
I'm very curious to learn how your
introversion has helped you be successful.
And further, I'd love to hear your advice,
tips or tricks you have for
many of our listeners who
consider themselves introverts.
And for
those of us who might not be introverted,
what we could do to help our
colleagues and our friends who are.
>> If one adopts the definition of
introvert, extrovert is in terms of how
you recharge, so, classically, extroverts
recharge by being immersed with others.
And introverts recharge by
being with themselves or
a very small group of people or
person that they have as
a particularly trusted adviser or
spouse, in my case, my wife.
And I think that that describes my
personality in terms of how I recharge.
Now, what I've learned about myself
in leadership in particular is,
one of the reasons I feel like I
have the best job on the planet is
that I interact with such a group
of amazingly bright people on
a daily basis through what I do at
Stanford University and Stanford Medicine.
And then more broadly as
a representative of Stanford and
as a leader in biomedicine.
And I derive a lot of energy
from those interactions and
from learning from others.
But in order to process and
really sort of plan,
then I need to have time to think and
sort things out individually or
with a small group of others.
>> Thank you for sharing that.
I think for those who listen and who are
introverted, to hear that their approach
is equally valuable and in some cases
more valuable can be very affirming.
And to recognize that we need both types
of people, those who are extroverted and
I fall into that category, and those who
are introverted to make things work well.
You mentioned listening in your response
to my question about introversion and
I was really struck by
a quote I heard of yours.
It went, one of the most active things
that I do is to listen, to process what
I'm hearing and to come up with informed
questions that bring us together.
Can you share your thoughts on
the importance of listening beyond
what you've already shared
around introversion and
provide us with any best practices
you personally use to listen well.
>> Sure, I think the most valuable
clerkship that I had in medical
school was my psychiatry clerkship.
And it's because of something
that our preceptor did for
the two of us students rotating
with our preceptor at that time.
And it was a six week rotation.
For every day, at least three days a week,
each of us would interview a patient.
We weren't allowed to take notes, and
the other person would be listening.
And after the interview,
each of us independently would write,
we were asked to write verbatim what we
heard during that 30 minute interview and
discussion with the patient.
And at first,
it was extraordinarily difficult, I mean,
it was just the hardest
thing in the world.
But it became, I wouldn't say easy, but it
became easier with time of the experience.
And the point is,
you really have to concentrate and
focus if you're going to really listen.
And I've tried to deploy that in
the other things I've done as a surgeon,
scientist, as a leader,
it really does help.
First, it helps to build trust in others
if they really can see that you're
listening.
It helps to really have a dialogue if
in addition to what you're saying,
you're actually heading what others say.
And that comes back in the way
you converse with them,
that they know that
you're listening to them.
I've always emphasized that I think
listening is the most important trait and
characteristic of leadership and
undergirds the success in every
other area of leadership.
And I don't think it receives enough
attention as we're talking about
leadership training.
And as we're talking about communication,
certainly what we say is important.
But it's even more important that what we
are saying is based upon what we're taking
in from listening to others.
>> So what I'm hearing you say really is
that you need to take the time to listen,
really focus and concentrate on it.
It is an important and
an act that requires a lot of attention.
And it can really breed connection and
validate others,
and that's an important
part of leadership.
And I agree,
as somebody who teaches communication,
a lot of what gets taught is,
how to say your piece,
not necessarily how to listen to
what the other people are saying.
During your tenure as the Dean of
the Stanford School of Medicine,
you've had to address many significant
issues happening on campus and beyond.
What are your thoughts on the role of
leaders and communication in times of
ambiguity and challenge,
any insights that you've learned?
>> I think one insight is when someone
doesn't know the answer to a question, or
when they answer to the question
is simply not known,
we need to say that we don't know.
And I think a lot of experts
early on in the pandemic,
that was problematic because
that really wasn't being stated.
And then there was so much we didn't know.
And in a sense, it's not reassuring,
but it's far more of a problem if
we try to pretend we do, and
then later on, of course, we didn't.
So I think being honest,
being forthright, following through,
if it's a specific question I simply don't
know the answer to, but the answer is out
there, then I should be finding out
the answer and then relaying that back.
The idea is rather than
pushing ambiguity away,
we should lean into it and
use it as a stimulus to guide
our communication in more effective ways
>> One of the things that I really
respected about you and some of your
colleagues who became front and center in
the news on a regular basis was the level
of transparency that you would admit,
we don't know.
Or we're learning, or we said this
one day and now we know this as well.
So, in addition to saying I don't know,
I think it's important to put
a focus on transparency as well.
And I saw that played out
often in your communication.
I've heard you talk about
authentic leadership.
Can you tell us what you mean by that and
why is this type of leadership so
important to you?
>> To me,
authenticity means being forthright,
being honest, being empathic, for sure.
It means putting yourself in
the shoes of the other person.
It means earning the right to be a leader,
which is something it doesn't come with
a title, it doesn't come with resources.
To be an effective leader,
you need to earn that right,
that privilege, that trust from
the people that you're leading.
And they look to you for leadership.
I think authenticity is something today
that particularly given the impact of
social media and
the immediacy of social media.
Oftentimes, authenticity is not
represented [LAUGH] in a soundbite or
in a tweet.
In fact, if anything,
it gets us further away from authenticity.
I think there's a basic yearning today
in society to have some bedrock truths,
to understand our differences better
than we do today, and to be authentic,
expressing those differences and
expressing those views.
But hopefully from the authenticity when
it exists on both sides of an issue,
when that authenticity is there,
that will actually help people work
together even though they disagree.
And I think we're sorely
lacking that right now.
>> I'm curious as you think
about authentic leadership,
what's the role of feedback?
It seems to me that feedback would
be an important part of that,
I'm curious how that works for you.
>> It's essential to building trust.
Another trait that helps in
building trust is to be vulnerable.
And goodness knows,
we were, all of us, but
particularly those of us in leadership,
have throughout COVID, whether or
not we acknowledged it or not,
we've been extraordinarily vulnerable.
And I think to acknowledge that,
look, we may not get this right and
we depend upon your feedback to
recalibrate and get it right,
that that's just absolutely essential.
By discipline,
I'm trained as a neurosurgeon,
as a lateral skull-based surgeon,
and those are highly precise fields.
And when I became provost at Johns
Hopkins, I stopped operating because if
you're not doing it regularly,
you shouldn't be doing it.
The point is that your best
opportunity to do good for
your patient is the first
time you do something and
do it absolutely textbook
right the first time.
And there is a clear right and wrong
with most things in my clinical field.
Leadership is very,
very different from that.
I find myself rarely do I
get it right the first time.
I depend upon the feedback of others,
unless this is a critically important
time-sensitive decision, and we were
faced with many of those during COVID.
In those cases, you do the best you
can and you recalibrate very quickly.
In cases that are not as acute
as they have been during COVID,
you can put up a straw person,
you can float an idea,
you can express your opinion and
your belief about,
this is the way I think we should go.
Some of that will be embraced,
some of it won't.
But if you take the feedback,
it's not going to affect your
credibility as a leader.
It's very different than
a surgical procedure.
You're going to tell a patient
before you do a surgical procedure,
I think I'm going to do it this way today,
but that may not work, and so
we'll then do something
different tomorrow or next week.
I mean, no one wants to hear that-
>> [LAUGH] Right.
>> And for me,
that was a recalibration as a leader.
I feel really fortunate to have had
kind of both sides represented.
And I think it's made me able to act
definitively when the circumstance
requires it and when people around
me expect me to act definitively.
And also to be more graduated and
incremental when the situation
justifies that approach.
>> I think it's great that you take the
time to reflect on feedback and to be so
open to it.
Before we end,
I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I asked everyone who joins me.
Are you up for that?
>> I sure am.
>> Excellent,
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received as
a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would that be?
>> Empathic listening for
impactful leadership.
>> I like it, and
it even has some rhyming to it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Question number two,
who is a communicator that you admire and
why?
>> Ruth Simmons,
Former President of Brown University,
Current President of Prairie View A&M.
I got to know Ruth when she was
president of Brown as a Brown alum.
Ruth asked me to serve on a corporation
committee on medical education many
years ago.
And I think Ruth's ability to lean
into complex controversial topics,
and through the strength
of her personality and
her intellect really get people
to do their best thinking
around an issue and
come up with recommendations.
I think she's extraordinary at that.
>> Final question,
what are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> Listen, learn, recalibrate,
I think to learn, you have to listen,
and we talked a lot about that today.
But you also had to be willing to say,
look, I probably got that wrong before,
and you've got to be willing to
say that first of yourself, and
then you've got to be willing
to say that to others.
And then seek the input from
others that help you and
others get it right moving forward.
Well, Dean Minor, thank you so
much for being here.
The work you and all of your colleagues
do at the Stanford Medical School is so
important.
And a personal thank you for
all that you and
everyone there did during the pandemic.
I appreciate your time and
your thoughtful and
thought provoking ideas and
actions around effective leadership, and
the importance of communication
in science and medicine.
Finally, best of luck on your podcast,
the Minor Consult.
Everyone listening in has a lot to
learn from you and your guests.
>> Thanks a lot, Matt.
[MUSIC]
>> You've been listening to
Think Fast Talk Smart, the Podcast,
a production of
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
This episode was produced by Michael
Riley, Jenny Luna, and me, Matt Abrahams.
Find more resources and
connect with us online by searching for
Think Fast Talk Smart on LinkedIn.
We'd love to connect there.
Be sure to follow us on LinkedIn as well.
Download more episodes and subscribe
to us wherever you get your podcasts.